[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
depuis un an l'hygiène est érigée comme
rempart à la pandémie mondiale grâce aux
fameux gestes barrières en théorie tout
le monde les connaît mais il reste
encore des progrès à faire
malheureusement l'hygiène des mains
n'est pas adopté de manière rigoureuse
je pense que si les pratiques étaient
respectées on le sait hygiène des mains
distance sociale on aurait même plus de
vagues des gestes d'hygiène de base qui
n'auraient pas encore pénétré toute la
société résultat le lavage des mains
s'essouffle
comme il faut se mettre de la bonne
volonté mais c'est pas forcément il est
de bien savoir désinfecter les mains
mais entre gestes barrières et hygiène
où est la réalité sanitaire tous les
dermatologues ne conseillent pas par
exemple une douche quotidienne il y a
des techniques qui sont de moins se
laver moins longtemps pour préserver en
fait le capital de la peau
alors quelles sont les bonnes habitudes
sanitaires les Français ont-ils un
problème avec l'hygiène c'est le thème
de ce numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro des tas de santé depuis
l'épidémie de covid un geste qui nous
semblait anodin est devenu essentiel
capital le lavage de mains érigé en
barrière absolue c'est la star de
l'hygiène et justement on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui à l'hygiène
est-ce qu'il faut se laver les mains
toutes les heures ce qu'il faut prendre
une douche tous les jours on en saura
plus à la fin de cette émission grâce à
vous bonjour professeur Le Peletier
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on va parler de lavage de main
évidemment énormément parce qu'encore
une fois c'est présenté comme la
barrière absolue anticovine mais on va
parler de l'hygiène en général et un
titre là les Français ont quand même
très mauvaises réputation vous vous êtes
médecin hygiéniste on y reviendra
elle est justifiée cette mauvaise
réputation c'est vrai qu'à l'occasion de
cette pandémie covid les Français qui
n'ont pas une culture de santé publique
dès l'école après finalement à tous ces
gestes barrières on voit quand même que
le Français s'est vite adapté si il tra
cette réputation quand on regarde les
études en sociologie sur l'adhésion des
Français depuis un an aux différentes
mesures on voit que finalement les
Français se sont acclimatés et ont été
assez adhérents sur le port de masques
en particulier dans les lieux communs
alors on le porte pas toujours bien mais
en tout cas on voit que les français
portent leur masque l'hygiène des masses
est plus compliqué lorsqu'on est dans la
communauté puisqu'on n'a pas accès
forcément à de l'eau et à du savon on
peut toujours avoir sur soi un produit
droit alcoolique bien évidemment mais ce
n'est pas naturel tout ça vous êtes le
spécialiste de l'hygiène et du lavage de
main votre portrait d'abord votre
parcours
[Musique]
le professeur Didier Le Peltier et
médecin hygiéniste et de santé publique
chef du Service d'Hygiène Hospitalière
du CHU de Nantes il qu'au président le
groupe de travail permanent covid-19 au
sein du Haut Conseil de la santé
publique il a piloté la rédaction de
nombreux rapports relatifs à l'hygiène
la prévention et le risque
environnemental en période pandémique à
la demande de la Direction générale de
la santé professeur des universités à la
faculté de Nantes il enseigne la
prévention le contrôle des infections et
l'hygiène hospitalière aux étudiants en
médecine enfin il peut dirige une équipe
de chercheurs autour des microbiote et
de la résistance bactérienne
[Musique]
professeur le pelty vous êtes donc
médecin hygiéniste et de santé publique
c'est une spécialité médicale la
médecine hygiéniste d'une part et
d'autre part bon vous n'êtes pas
clinicien du coup vous faites quoi alors
le métier d'hygiéniste en fait est de
déployer des activités de surveillance
et prévention des infections tout
d'abord en milieu de soins mais on le
voit à travers cette pandémie également
dans la communauté
donc l'hygiène vient de la déesse IgA
qui était la déesse de la santé mentale
et de l'hygiène on voit qu'on a eu un
manque d'hygiène à travers les siècles
mais toutes les règles d'asepsie
d'antisepsie était connu dès le début du
20e siècle mais que la vaccination les
antibiotiques au milieu du 20e siècle on
fait un petit peu oublier toutes ces
règles d'hygiène que l'on redécouvre à
l'occasion de cette pandémie donc être
hygiéniste être médecin ou pharmacien
c'est passé à l'internat de santé
publique de biologie de maladies
infectieuses c'est des gens qui ont
tourné autour du risque infectieux et
qui a un moment donné embrasse une
carrière ce qu'on appelle transversale
il y a plus d'activités cliniques on ne
voit plus de patients en tant que tel
dans leur prise en charge mais en fait
on
déploie des stratégies pour améliorer la
sécurité infectieuse lors des soins
alors c'est un peu votre ordre de gloire
enfin à tous les hygiénistes puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de l'hygiène maintenant
mais il y a forcément un médecin
hygiéniste par hôpital vous êtes
celui qui enfin la vigie des maladies
nosocomiales j'imagine voilà c'est ça
donc en fait à partir des années 2000
par textes réglementaire des circulaires
ou des décrets d'applications les
hôpitaux ont été tenus de constituer des
équipes opérationnelles d'hygiène avec
des pharmaciens ou des médecins
hygiénistes alors je dis à tout à
l'heure
on revient de loin une certaine façon
sans oublier français qu'on était très
sale ça va mieux tant mieux mais on va
quand même regarder quelques chiffres
infographie
[Musique]
c'est un cliché tenace à l'étranger les
Français sont sales qu'en est-il
réellement de manière générale l'hygiène
s'est améliorée depuis les années 50 il
y a peu de chiffres mais on sait qu'à
l'époque la moitié des français
seulement prenait une douche quotidienne
mais il reste encore des progrès à faire
notamment au niveau du lavage des mains
selon une étude de l'Ifop 30% des
Français ne se lavent pas
systématiquement les mains après être
allé aux toilettes la moitié avant de
manger et à peine un tiers le font après
avoir pris les transports mais les
femmes seraient plus disciplinées elles
sont plus nombreuses à faire une
toilette quotidienne et mettent plus
souvent leur sous-vêtements au linge
sale 94% en change tous les jours contre
seulement 73% des hommes en confinement
on se laisse un peu aller sur l'hygiène
corporelle - 2 douches - Deux shampoing
mais plus de lavage de mains et ça se
ressent dans les magasins déjà on déclin
régulier depuis quelques années les
ventes de certains produits d'hygiène
vous chuter pendant le premier
confinement moins 27% pour les
shampoings - 26% pour les dentifrices et
même moins 45% pour les déodorants en
revanche la consommation de gel
hydroalcoolique explose elle a été
multipliée par 10 mais nous ne sommes
pas tous égaux face à l'hygiène qui
reste très liée à l'âge à l'isolement
social et au moyen financiers
rappelons que 3 millions de Français
n'ont pas accès aux produits de base
comme le savon la lessive ou le
dentifrice
alors professeur Le Pelletier question
très pratique on est là pour répondre un
Français sur trois on vient de le voir
ne se lave pas les mains en sortant des
toilettes est-ce que c'est grave Docteur
est-ce que c'est un risque en tant que
tel oui c'est un risque puisque
l'homme porte autant de bactéries sur sa
peau ce qu'on appelle le microbiote
cutané que de cellules humaines donc
bien évidemment
lorsqu'on se serre les mains lorsqu'on
touche des objets ou du mobilier urbain
partagé on va récupérer la flore cutanée
faite de bactéries des personnes qui
vous entourent
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc
est-ce que c'est grave ne pas se laver
les mains parce que vous pouvez toucher
des matières fécales vous pouvez toucher
des
urines qui peuvent être en fait ce qu'on
appelle des réservoirs de bactéries
résistantes qui ont été finalement
contractés lors d'une précédente
hospitalisation ou d'un parent qui est
lui-même a été
à l'hôpital ou d'un parent qui travaille
en milieu de soins et donc faire une
hygiène des mains en sortant des
toilettes est un geste qui doit être
citoyen mais si vous écoute c'est
tellement important il y a tellement de
risques partout qu'il faudrait se laver
les mains dès qu'on dès qu'on se déplace
dès qu'on fait un geste tout le temps
non il y a des opportunités vous avez
cité les cabinets de toilettes mais ça
peut être aussi après cette moucher ou
là en cette période c'est quand je
rentre dans un supermarché dans un
magasin ou quand j'en sors donc c'est
petit je vais dans le métro quand je
vais dans ma voiture
vers l'excès mais par exemple si je veux
en visite à mes grands-parents en cette
période c'est quand même bien de faire
une hygiène des mains quand je sors de
chez eux je fais une hygiène des mains
en fait c'est trouver les situations
dans lesquelles je vais mettre un risque
mon environnement ou quand je vais me
mettre à risque et quelqu'un vous
connaissez bien qui s'appelle Didier
Pitel qui est en Suisse qui est
d'ailleurs a été chargée de de mission
pour vérifier la gestion de crise en
France par le président Macron mais il
est connu parce que il a été il a
contribué à la fabrication
d'un gel hydroalcoolique mis à
disposition tous les équipes de l'état
de santé sont allés le voir à Genève
justement dans son hôpital reportage
Sébastien villa et Alexia les peaux
[Musique]
ce geste on commence à le connaître par
coeur à l'entrée de chaque lieu public
c'est toujours le même rituel une
pression un peu de gel et on frotte mais
est-ce qu'on sait vraiment bien le faire
dans cet hôpital de Genève on a décidé
de vérifier
alors tu mets ta main droite comme ça
les doigts un peu écarter cette machine
détecte les zones mal des infectées
pour réussir le test il faudrait que 95%
au moins de la surface de la main soit
bien désinfectée et pour l'instant la
moyenne n'est qu'à 80%, il reste encore
du travail
les personnes ont parfois l'impression
de faire comme il faut se mettre de la
bonne volonté mais c'est pas forcément
inné de bien savoir désinfecter les
masses vraiment une apprentissage à
faire 3 millilitres alors voici la bonne
méthode donc je verse le produit par la
paume de ma main je viens désinfecter le
bout des doigts de ma main droite parce
que je suis droitier donc c'est très
théoriquement ce qui est le plus
contaminé chez moi le bout des doigts la
clé d'un bon lavage de main
après voilà je frotte mes mains
répartissant bien le tout c'est d'avoir
pris une quantité suffisante pour que
les mains soient entièrement mouillées
ça va durer 15 secondes 20 secondes ça a
été très rapide si tous ces gestes sont
aussi importants c'est parce qu'à
l'hôpital on surveille de près les
bactéries pour mieux comprendre
direction le laboratoire d'hygiène ici
on observe l'ennemi et l'une des
méthodes cette petite boîte pour être
posée sur la surface tenir appuyer un
petit moment la veille le chercheur a
effectué un prélèvement sur un
distributeur de billets voici le
résultat le lendemain chaque petit point
est une colonie formée par les bactéries
qui étaient présentes sur les touches du
clavier avec mes doigts et que je tapote
sur le distributeur je vais récupérer
les bactéries sur le bout de mes doigts
je sais qu'après avoir fait quelque
chose comme ça il faut pas que je me
touche les yeux ou la bouche ou le nez
ou je ne sais quoi sur les mains du
personnel hospitalier ces bactéries
peuvent avoir des conséquences
dramatiques pour les patients les
infections nosocomiales pour les
combattre les soignants une arme la
solution hydro-alcoolique
c'est ici même dans la pharmacie de cet
hôpital de Genève qu'elle a été mise au
point dans les années 90
et c'est grâce à cet homme le professeur
Didier Pittet que son usage est répandu
dans le monde entier
l'hygiène des mains il en a fait son
combat voyageant à travers le monde pour
promouvoir l'utilisation de la solution
hydroalcoolique on sait que les
infections liées aux soins dite
nosocomiales compliquent 10% des
hospitalisations elle compliquait 15% il
y a il y a 20 ans aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'on est de l'ordre de 5 à 6% dans les
meilleures hôpitaux au monde et que plus
de la moitié de toutes ces infections
sont prévenus par une bonne hygiène des
mains en vingt ans c'est donc environ
trois fois moins de maladies
nosocomiales grâce à la désinfection des
mains pour le professeur pité cette
pratique devrait s'étendre à la
population entière pour lutter
efficacement contre la pandémie mais ce
n'est pas gagné malheureusement
l'hygiène des mains n'est pas adoptée de
manière rigoureuse je pense que si les
pratiques étaient respectées on le sait
hygiène des mains distance on aurait
même plus de vagues et par rapport à des
virus qu'on connaît bien d'autres virus
respiratoires comme le virus de la
grippe
l’hygiène des mains fait davantage que
le port du masque dans la limitation de
la transmission du virus de la grippe on
ne connaît pas les résultats pour le
covid 19 pour l'instant mais c'est un
virus respiratoire comme les autres donc
il y a pas de raison que ce soit bien
différent
en effet entre les deux confinements une
enquête ifope sur le lavage des mains
révèle un relâchement alors que 86% des
Français se lavaient les mains
systématiquement en rentrant chez eux en
mars il n'était plus que 63% en octobre
alors pourquoi les bonnes habitudes ne
prennent pas selon cette sociologue qui
a étudié l'hygiène des Français cela
pourrait s'expliquer car l'hygiène
moderne a pénétré nos foyers à ces
tardivement jusque dans les années 50
plus de la moitié des Français n'avaient
même pas accès à l'eau courante quand on
fait le bilan en 51 il y a que 6% de
salle de bains en France donc la
question est grave
et il y a des publicités qui disent pas
de santé sans hygiène vous êtes parents
vous devez vous occuper de la santé de
vos enfants etc donc il y a un grand une
grande campagne pour faire que les
Français se lavent et installent des
salles de bain chez eux aujourd'hui 95%
des Français sont équipés d'une salle de
bain mais les bons réflexes d'hygiène ne
sont pas encore complètement adoptés
pour avoir les mains propres il faudra
encore faire des efforts
[Musique]
une en pratique
quand je vais retirer 50 euros un
distributeur je pose mes petits doigts
sur les petites touches là je prends des
bactéries et effectivement donc il
faudrait que j'aille me laver les mains
derrière pas forcément puisque notre
microbiote cutanée
intestinal il y a un microbiote
pulmonaire et donc il y a mis ce mode
cutané on a à peu près 10 puissance 3
c'est-à-dire 1000 bactéries par
centimètre carré sur notre peau quand on
se serre la main c'est un échange
courtois de bactéries mais ce sont des
bactéries qu'on appelle Commencal Mansa
en latin ça veut dire table ce sont des
bactéries qui sont bénéfiques en fait
pour on appelle ça la symbiose pour
notre organisme et donc ces bactéries là
il faut les préserver elles sont
nécessaires à l'équilibre de notre peau
constitue une barrette
absolument mais ça c'est important toute
bactérie ne présente pas un risque
majeur non parce que ça peut tourner à
l'obsession aussi il faut pas non plus
se laver trop souvent les mains on
rencontre des gens tous les jours
maintenant qu'on a du gel pourtant qui
disent j'ai les mains abîmées donc il
faut faire attention au gel faut faire
attention à la fréquence il faut alors
la fréquence elle est elle est vraiment
comment dire soumise au nombre
d'opportunités de d'hygiène des mains
que vous faites en fonction des patients
que vous prenez en charge ce qu'il faut
c'est s'occuper de ses mains en période
hivernale ou les mains sont sèches par
le climat dans ce crémer les mains le
matin avant de partir le soir avant de
rentrer évitez de mettre ses mains sous
l'eau à la maison et plutôt porter des
gants quand on est par exemple dans sa
cuisine on parlait de l'hygiène des
mains on va parler de l'hygiène tout
court est-ce qu'il faut par exemple
prendre une douche tous les jours on
regarde le reportage et on en parle
juste après professeur regardez
[Musique]
dans les rayons des supermarchés les
marques rivalisent de créativité pour
vanter les mérites de savon toujours
plus doux plus respectueux de la peau
mais est-ce que ces produits prennent
vraiment soin des peaux sensibles au CHU
de Lyon ce n'est pas la vie de cette
dermatologue spécialiste des peaux
fragiles donc la zone qui est
problématique encore pour vous c'est le
dos c'est ça vous permettez que je
soulève
alors oui effectivement là on a plus que
de la peau sèche on a aussi de l'eczéma
dans tout le dos parce que vous arrivez
quand on a de l'eczéma l'hygiène peut
vite devenir un casse-tête quotidien
mais l'un des conseils est en fait assez
simple c'est pour ça que il y a des
techniques qui sont de moins se laver
moins longtemps pour préserver en fait
le capital de la peau en faire moins
quand on a un problème de peau ça ne va
pas forcément de soi alors la
dermatologue veut bien faire passer le
message on va revenir sur la case de
départ qui est vraiment l'ennemi de la
peau sèche qui se trouve dans la salle
de bain pour moi le premier ennemi de la
peau c'est le savon qui est un produit
détergent oui effectivement le savant ça
sert à émulsionner le gras c'est-à-dire
à enlever le gras et déjà dans la peau
sèche sèche ça veut dire qu'elle manque
d'eau mais en fait elle manque d'eau
parce qu'elle manque de gras donc l'eau
s'évaporer donc effectivement c'est pas
la peine d'enlever déjà le peu de gras
qui reste ce grain est appelé film
hydrolipidique et il est nécessaire à la
bonne santé de la peau mais alors qu'en
est-il de tous ces produits du commerce
qui se disent bon pour la
regardez tout ce que vous avez à tout de
suite elle repère le célèbre savon de
Marseille
on entend très souvent le savon de
Marseille c'est ce qui a de mieux c'est
le plus simple c'est le premier c'est ce
qu'il y a de mieux mais le savon il faut
le savoir c'est un produit qui décape la
peau et donc toutes les peaux sensibles
vont réagir et il y a un deuxième
problème le pH de nos produits ou degré
d'acidité et là l'étiquette peut parfois
porter à confusion donc quand vous voyez
sur un flacon écrit pH neutre en règle
c'est le pH neutre au sens chimique du
mot donc le pH neutre c'est 7 et 7 c'est
déjà un peu trop par rapport à une peau
normale qui est à 5,5 et d'autant plus
quand c'est une peau fragile et le
troisième constat si surtout ces flacons
le label sans parfum n'apparaît pas ce
qui sont tous parfumés et il y a des
peaux qui ne supportent pas et parfums
des savons trop agressifs mais ce n'est
pas tout ils appauvriraient aussi notre
fleur cutanée car notre peau est peuplé
de microbes et de bactéries pour le voir
direction l'Inserm à Lyon avec une
petite expérience le prélèvement du
microbiote cutané et assez simple je
vais le je vais le réaliser sur moi
grâce à ce prélèvement le chercheur
récupère les bactéries présentes à la
surface de sa peau
puis après cette lavé au savon il
renouvelle l'opération
le lendemain on récupère nos boîtes et
voici le résultat sans le savon à gauche
et une boîte de culture avec le savon à
droite on voit clairement que un simple
lavage au savon détruit une grande
partie du microbiote cutané mais on ne
doit pas à tout prix se débarrasser de
ces microbes présents naturellement sur
la peau bien au contraire le microbiote
cutané profite de notre peau et en
retour notre peau profite de ce
microbiote en récupérant les acides gras
qui fabrique ces microbiote en étant
protégé également par cet ensemble de
microbes contre des pathogènes
un équilibre appelé symbiose qui est
donc essentiel pour protéger la peau
désinfection
on a théoriquement pas besoin de d'avoir
un excès d'hygiène de rajouter des
savons de rajouter tout un tas de choses
pour modifier la biologie de la peau la
nature est bien faite on a un équilibre
entre les deux
et si le mieux c'était d'arrêter le
savon tout simplement
depuis trois ans je me lave
exclusivement à l'eau au niveau du corps
donc sans savon et au niveau sur les
réseaux sociaux ils sont plusieurs à
avoir franchi le pas du nosso ou sans
savon convaincu par ce témoignage j'ai
le huiz elle-même blogueuse a décidé de
suivre le mouvement une démarche qui
peut susciter des appréhensions
les personnes qui n'ont jamais testé
sont parfois retenus en fait par une
barrière un peu psychologique le fait de
se dire bah voilà on a peur d'avoir ces
odeurs on a peur aussi par rapport au
regard des autres au jugement une fois
cette barrière franchie c'était pour
elle une réussite je crois que je ne
suis laissé passer un mois à peu près
avant d'en parler à mon mari il n'avait
rien remarqué du tout moi j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir un petit peu moins
de soucis de peau alors j'ai pas non
plus de gros gros soucis de peau mais je
trouve que effectivement j'ai moins de
boutons
la démarche est encore marginale
aujourd'hui mais ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à dire adieu alors gel
douche une bonne hygiène pour eux n'est
plus synonyme de savonnage quotidien
alors professeur Le Pelletier on a une
curiosité après ce reportage se laver à
l'eau sans savon puisque les savons
peuvent irriter la peau qu'est-ce que
vous en dites vous le médecin hygiéniste
j'ai vu quelques expériences
effectivement ou des personnes
finalement abandonnées le savon et après
une première période de 3-4 jours on a
l'impression de se sentir ça ou de
sentir mauvais finalement il y a un
effet bénéfique et les gens se passent
finalement de de savon ce que j'entends
c'est que vous ne le déconseillez pas
vous ne dites pas cela vers l'eau c'est
un défaut d'hygiène effectivement en
fonction de votre nature de peau si vous
avez une peau fragile si vous avez
peut-être des maladies de peau
préexistantes comme un eczéma je pense
qu'il est de bons conseils d'aller voir
son dermatologue ou un médecin pour
qu'il puisse choisir avec vous la bonne
crème pour vous créer votre peau mais
également le bon gel douche pour ne pas
d'une part trop en utiliser mais
également ne pas finalement avoir
l'effet paradoxal d'avoir une méditation
voir une allergie par certains copeaux
vous êtes mesuré on a l'impression que
trop propre ça pourrait être néfaste
pour la santé pas exagéré non non
absolument pas c'est une sensation
personnelle qui est la propreté et sans
aller prendre trois quatre douches par
jour une douche par jour est suffisant
une douche tous les deux jours tout tout
dépend en fait de son mode de vie de sa
transpiration de son envie de sentir
propre donc je pense qu'il faut que
chacun soit tout à fait libre dans la
façon d'utiliser des produits on va dire
cosmétiques mais dès lors que une
personne a des problèmes de peau d'un
irritation une maladie de peau se faire
conseiller et choisir le bon produit et
une attitude tout à fait adaptée en ce
qui concerne
les mains toujours on a observé un petit
relâchement entre le premier deuxième
confinement en France autant le masque
est très porté il y a un petit peu moins
de réflexe des mains vous l'avez observé
vous-même on l'a observé dans les études
sur les sociologues où on voit que les
l'hygiène des mains finalement le masque
semble la seule mesure qui baisse un
petit peu en termes d'observance des
Français mais qui se maintient à un haut
niveau toutes les autres mesures de la
doctrine du Haut Conseil de la santé
publique qui associe finalement la
distance inter-individuelle d'au moins 1
m maintenant on est passé à 2 mètres
comme les pays anglo-saxons le fait de
respecter l'ensemble des gestes
barrières utiliser un mouchoir les
agunique ne pas se serrer la main ne pas
s'embrasser le fait de faire une hygiène
des mains puis le port du masque et ça
finalement c'est les quatre mesures en
même temps qui sont efficaces professeur
le petit vous médecin hygiéniste est-ce
que vous voudriez qu'à l'école il y a
des cours de lavage demain désormais ad
vitam eternam que ce soit une matière
comme les maths stress oui oui il y a un
manque de santé publique finalement dans
les dans les écoles et que un des succès
de cette pandémie si on peut le dire sur
le plan pédagogique c'est de retenir ces
gestes barrières alors qu'on a beaucoup
vu à la télévision qui ont peut-être un
un peu lasser les Français mais ce sont
des gestes barrières qui va falloir
ressortir alors pas tout le temps pas
l'été pas forcément au printemps mais
lorsqu'on est en saison hivernale de
maladies transmissibles donc je pense à
la gastro-entérite et je pense à la
grippe qui sont des maladies mais qui
qui n'ont pas émergé dans l'hiver
austral en
Nouvelle-Zélande ou en Australie et on
s'aperçoit exactement de la même chose
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de grippe en
France probablement par l'effet de ces
mesures
maternelle il y ait un cours d'hygiène
des mains désormais imposés pour tous
les enfants il faut trouver le moyen le
plus pédagogique et ludique chez les
enfants non non non c'est quelque chose
qu'on pourrait absolument faire les
enseigner le plus tôt possible dans nos
générations
en France c'est une c'est une excellente
démarche de santé publique merci
beaucoup professeur Le Pelletier d'avoir
été avec nous d'être venu de Nantes sur
le plateau d'état de santé bonne journée
à très vite pour un prochain numéro
d'état de santé
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé